[EXCITING MUSIC]
The lands of the prehistoric planet
were ruled by the dinosaurs, but the seas
dominated by a very different group
of reptiles, the mosasaurs.
And this is the skull of one of them.
Mosasaurs were seagoing lizards.
Think of a giant, swimming, whale-sized Komodo dragon.
Tapered snout, rough skin, four fins instead of normal limbs,
and a long tail that would look a lot like a shark tail
but upside down.
That's basically a mosasaur.
The largest was mosasaurus hoffmanni.
It was an ambush predator.
But what was the secret of its success?
They can move from just still, not
moving at all, to incredible speeds right before your eyes.
In the modern world, we see this ability
in reptiles like crocodiles.
[SPLASHING]
Their muscles can deliver short bursts of tremendous power.
Mosasaurs given that they're reptiles,
given that they're lizards, probably
had similar capabilities in their muscles.
They also had another adaptation that could increase
the element of surprise.
One of the tricky things about swimming
is you need a special kind of dynamic to get out of the gate
quickly, to do the equivalent of a sprinter start
from the blocks.
And one of the best ways of doing that
is to bend yourself into a C shape
and then push off of the water of the side of your body.
Fish today use this technique.
Known as a sea start, it allows them
to accelerate from a standstill to full speed in an instant.
Mosasaurs likely were able to do something very similar
but, of course, at a much grander scale.
So exactly how fast could a giant
like mosasaurus hoffmanni actually swim?
To find out, the Prehistoric Planet team
commissioned a unique scientific study.
Until recently, no one had really
attempted to estimate these kinds of performance values
in detail.
Our work is one of the first attempts
to really put numbers to the abilities of these animals.
And the results we got from that are really pretty stunning.
The team ran the calculations four times
to ensure they were correct.
All four of the different trials came
to the same overall conclusion.
These animals were able to generate massive accelerations.
[SPLASH]
This mosasaur could probably clear
75% of its body length in one single second.
That means if that mosasaur is 17 meters away from you, in one
second it will be 75% closer.
And in the second second, it would
have surpassed you and probably eaten you along the way.
Being hit by a mosasaurus would be
a bit like being hit by a full size semi truck.
Just the impact of the animal alone,
much less the bite that would follow
would kill a lot of its prey instantly.
Mosasaurs could reach 30 miles an hour
in as little as one second.
This is what makes them arguably the ultimate marine predator
of all time.
[EXCITING MUSIC]